de la précision de la concentration
c'était la recette pour remporter le
concours annuel organisé depuis 25 ans
par les archers de guyancourt
cette année 26 ils ont été installés
dans le gymnase maurice baquet pour
programme des duels pour mettre les
compétiteurs dans les conditions d'un
championnat officiel donc les gens font
leurs tirs sélectifs et à la fin nous
mélangeons par arm les personnes pour
qui les faire un classement ce qu'on
appelle un classement scratch et on
retient les 16 meilleurs de ceux qui ont
décidé de participer aux finales
un programme qui est séduit les archers
de la région parisienne le tournoi
affiché complet avec plus de 240
participants le samedi et 104 pour le
dimanche je suis toujours fiable
participer parce que c'est vraiment des
gens super où il ya vraiment une bonne
ambiance et puis ce principe de faire
des confessions et les duels c'est
vraiment très bien dans la mesure où il
ya très peu de clubs qui organisent des
finales il ya beaucoup d'archers qui
viennent rechercher cet entraînement et
du coup il ya de très bon marché dont le
niveau est tout de suite beaucoup plus
relevée que d'habitude
parmi les archers des têtes d'affiché
sébastien peineau champion du monde
individuel en quarts en 2016 est venu
supporter les sportifs thomas fauchereau
membre de l'équipe de france sur les jo
de 2012 est lui venu se tester avant la
nouvelle saison
pratique personnelle j'ai fait pas mal
de changements techniques en début de
saison
des changements majeurs donc le but
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment d'essayer de
poser les changements que j'ai effectués
et de dérouler ma technique le plus
convenablement possible thomas faucheron
a remporté la finale de l'arc classique
hommes face à valentin ripaud rendez
vous l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition